und mein kollege kai franke steht jetzt
am tatort an der partymeile die jetzt
sicher erst mal keine mehr sein wird was
wissen wir über den polizisten wissen
wir irgendetwas über seinen
gesundheitszustand wie geht es ihm ja
heute morgen kommen endlich mal eine
positive nachricht nach diesem schlimm
was hier abgegangen ist nämlich es von
der intensivstation auf die normale
station verlegt worden
leidet aber immer noch an einem schweren
schädel hirn trauma hat mehrere
frakturen im gesicht und auch den
kollegen also das muss man sich eben
reinziehen dem ein kollege wurde die
nase bei dieser tat da gebrochen und
auch andere polizisten erlitten chef von
dazu muss man eben sagen der polizist
ist erst seit vier jahren jetzt in
dieser gehobenen stelle hat zwei kinder
und bank tatsächlich kurze zeit um sein
leben
und kai wissen wir jetzt wer tatsächlich
alles in diesem vorfall verwickelt war
naja die polizei macht tatsächlich ein
staatsgeheimnis daraus man kann zu
stehen es geht eben um einen polizisten
was wir von unseren informationen aus
wissen ist dass der dort von dem zeitlos
dass sie hinter mir sehen
auch da seine anteile mit man hat er war
mit in dieser folge live dabei
allerdings muss man sagen dass diese
prügelei also die polizei wurde zu
dieser massenschlägerei gerufen
die war dann eigentlich wieder hat sich
die lage beruhigt und daneben kam die
polizei dann eskalierte es noch einmal
weil eben laut polizei die täter so
aggressiv auf die zu gehen und die
polizei keine andere wahl hatte als eben
den wir nennen ihn marvin zu taser und
das ganze ist ja vor einer gaststätte
passiert eigentlich ein ort wo es ein
gut gehen soll wo man spaß haben soll
wie ist denn jetzt die stimmung vor ort
also die stimmung ist ich weiß nicht ob
man mir das an merkt ich selber komme
aus dieser stadt war mehrmals in dieser
kneip vorher diese stadt lebt eigentlich
von freude freut sich über alles ist
eine fußballstadt freitags bis samstags
ist hier eben auch in dieser straße noch
mal party
und diese tat diese unfassbar
schreckliche tat dies wie ein schwarzer
nebel über dieser stadt
ich bin gestern mal durch die stadt
gegangen normal ist eben samstags auch
was los die leute gehen essen
es ist es unfassbar eine traurige
stimmung es gibt kaum was das ist also
wenn man andere nachher ist im moment
ganz schwierig da kann man merkt es ja
auf jeden fall anders so auch betroffen
ist und wir wünschen natürlich allen
alles gute an den polizisten hoffentlich
geht es ihm bald wieder besser
danke für dich erstmal für diesen moment
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren